from ancient times to prohibition to
happy hour beer has always been a
cornerstone of social gathering
today it's an industry dominated by a
few big companies but the recent growth
of craft breweries is disrupting the 100
billion dollar industry in 2013 craft
beer sales were up 17% while overall
beer sales declined 2% and craft beer
has grabbed 8% of the market the Brewers
Association hopes to reach 20% in six
years
reaching that goal means the 3,000 craft
brewers in the US will need to ramp up
production and distribution but building
that capacity brings more risk for small
Brewers who don't enjoy the same
economies of scale of massive Brewers
that's where Tim's shown former sales
and marketing executive at
anheuser-busch sees opportunity via CEO
of brew hub a new company creating a
unique partnership with select craft
brewers to increase output I like to
call the brew pub B&B it's essentially a
brewing and business services platform
what do you need to get that beer once
we brew it how does it get to the
consumer a lot of complexity there so we
have all those services available to
that particular craft brewery from
buying hops to bonding beer brew hub
offers a full-service long term
partnership helping small Brewers like
Florida cigar city focus on what's
important their craft
I love running boards I love developing
new products you know I love the
interaction with the consumer I keep
building booties five-year old cigar
city proved nearly 35,000 barrels at
their Tampa brew house last year with
brew hubs help they could add another
20,000 barrels to their output in the
next year alone we've always sort of
been chasing capacity we've been in
perpetual expansion that we've almost
since we began assume you're paying some
sort of premium for their service yeah
you're definitely leaving a little bit
of margin on the table but you're also
very much limiting your your your
exposure
those risks can include taking on debt
and the distraction that comes with
running a complicated brew brew hub is
building a network of five US breweries
to be within 350 miles of 70% of beer
drinkers that will allow vers popular in
one region to more easily take their
beers to drinkers in other parts of the
country while keeping the product intact
in beer in freshness matters so
closeness proximity to the end consumer
is very important the first brew hub
opened outside Tampa last week and the
second just announced will be built in
st. Louis the u.s. home of the world's
largest brewer anheuser-busch InBev
state-of-the-art brewing equipment
access to expert brew masters and the
power of scale and collaboration it's
how brew hub wants to take craft beer to
the next level guy from cigar City owes
some points said somebody asked him to
show you worried your beers gonna be
worse and he said no my fear is it's
going to be better